they were drinking the beer yeah they
pulled out a couple Bud Lights drinking
in solidarity it kind of like
tongue-in-cheek but the sand Talent is
like yo I love Bud light's great it's my
favorite beer you know how how could Bud
like be someone's favorite beer I think
he said it was his favorite beer but I
just think you could drink 20 of them
really you can drink like six of them
because they're not really hot they're
not really thick it's the fluoride and
the cost of uh calcifying of the pineal
gland that gets people addicted towards
destroying their frequencies right it's
the kind of beer yes yeah but it's the
kind of beer you drink if you just want
to get drunk and you don't really care
about the flavor as the joke goes it's
the kind of beer you drink when you
don't want to drink beer but you want to
drink a lot of it
I didn't write that I saw that on on
Reddit or something I thought it was
brilliant but I heard that Joe Rogan
cracked open a beer and they're like ah
it's no big deal and it's like you know
what I wonder about this uh I wonder if
you know when Joe was on YouTube more on
YouTube he could more see the direct
impact of his comments and and what
people thought about them